Diana Egerton-Warburton
Many people didn't realise the severity of the 2009 heatwave emergency across
south-eastern Australia.
The severe spike in Victorian deaths has left Melbourne's morgue full.
We have had an unprecedented demand upon our services.
If you have neighbours, check on those neighbours,
make sure that they're okay.
This is an extreme weather event that we've never experienced before.
Around 450 across the whole of south-eastern Australia died during that
three- and four-day period and in the emergency department, we had to institute
our disaster management process to manage the demand that occurred.
We had stretchers on ambulances lined up with fans and cooling bottles
that we just literally had to go down and get from a hardware store. At one stage,
a number of hospitals lost power and lost air-conditioning.
We had so many people lined up to come into the emergency department that we
couldn't close the electronic doors.
So our air-conditioning was ineffective. And I think a lot of that was under-recognised, both
by the general community and by policymakers.